we had a mix of clouds and sunshine all
weekend long
as the system was really starting to
pound california through the weekend
with rain and snow and wind and we were
getting some of the clouds
out ahead of it and a whole lot of the
wind so now we've got the clouds
and the opportunity for some rain
showers moving in for our monday
temperatures
right here in the mid 50s southwest
winds at 25 miles an hour
we're about 10 degrees cooler
valley-wide than we were yesterday
5 53 the sunrise the near full moon set
earlier about 5 30 behind the spring
mountains and it was beautiful
tonight it will be the full pink moon
for the month of april absolutely
gorgeous if we can find it because we
expect to keep a lot of clouds around
tonight as well
a lot of 50s on the west side some low
60s hanging on
aleonte downtown nellis and green valley
we've had gusts over 50 miles an hour up
at kyle canyon
near 50 at red rock mccarran almost 45
in southern highlands
over 40. those are some of the highest
ones and between pahrump and
up at mountain springs summit up between
pahrump and las vegas
it's been quite windy as well ragweed
olive grasses all still blooming out
there and swirling around
so the jet stream's taking a big dive
down and now it's pulling what's left of
this pacific storm into our area
first up through southern california and
into our area
so as nate mentioned earlier seeing some
showers developing in eastern clark
county
out towards the lake in northeastern
clark county all red flag warnings and
wind advisories have now shifted over
into utah and arizona
but we're still going to stay pretty
breezy to bumpy windy with southwest
winds
up to about 25 35 miles an hour today no
wind advisories
70 degrees maybe but with the clouds may
only be upper 60s today
with a chance of scattered showers snow
in the mountains above 6000 feet and i
think that will come really
later in the day into tonight when
temperatures cool even more
and then we'll look for northerly
breezes tomorrow with just a
20 percent chance of some showers left
and then temperatures
take off will recover quickly 80s
wednesday
look at near 100 degrees friday saturday
unbelievable warmth that it's about a 30
30 degree swing from monday to friday
wow get those ac's ready you're going to
need them by the weekend